yg je voudrais évoquer avec vous la
situation de vincent lambert et le débat
comme l'émoi qu'il suscite dans le pays
et je voudrais le faire sans céder aux
tentations qui dans cette affaire peut
tous nous guetter quelles que soient nos
convictions intimes celle des postures
était bleed avance des certitudes tout
fait
devant une telle situation ayons
l'humilité ou plutôt l'humanité de
compatir et l'humilité de reconnaître
compatir parce qu'au delà des positions
des uns ou des autres
il y à un drame il ya le silence d'un
homme il ya la douleur déchirante d'une
famille déchirée exposés sur la place
publique
il ya aussi la détresse d'une épouse et
l'espérance d'une mère reconnaître car
reconnaissons que ni le droit ni la
médecine ne nous offrent des réponses
at-il indiscutable l'institution
médicale est divisée quant à
l'institution judiciaire
l'arrêt rendu hier soir par la cour
d'appel de paris démontrent que sur le
plan du droit également des
interrogations demeurent
alors qui croire que croire il n'ya pas
michaud collègues de certitudes qui
c'est ici dans cet hémicycle ce que veut
vincent lambert qui pourrait affirmer
savoir ce qu'est les médecins eux mêmes
ne savent pas ayant la force d'esprit et
de coeur d'admettre que nous ne savons
pas peut-être devrions-nous nous
interroger avec humilité sur des deux
questions fondamentales que je vous pose
mer les ministres d'abord jusqu'où
pouvons nous considérer qu'une vie ne
vaut plus la peine d'être vécue et puis
enfin l'incertitude le doute elle des
décisions parfois contradictoires dans
cette terrible affaire font craindre à
beaucoup de français le risque d'une
dérive préjudiciable aux plus fragiles
une sorte d' insécurité éthiques
ne faut-il pas modern ministre tirer dès
à présent sur les leçons de ce
drame je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et callable madame la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bernard fournier
je crois pouvoir dire que comme beaucoup
de français nous sommes touche nombreux
ici à être bouleversés par cette
situation par ce drame familial elle
touche à l'intimé de chacun d'entre nous
vous le savez l'état français a toujours
été soucieux de s'assurer que
l'application de la procédure d'arrêt de
traitement en cas d'obstination
déraisonnable respectait le cadre de la
loi claisse les nets y voter en 2016
hier soir la cour d'appel de paris a
accepté la requête des parents de
vincent humbert et a ordonné la reprise
des traitements afin de faire exécuter
les recommandations du comité des droits
des personnes handicapées de l'onu
l'équipe médicale en charge de vincent
lambert appliquera ces mesures
provisoires
je n'en dirai pas davantage sur ce cas
particulier
aujourd'hui encore plus que jamais nous
devons respecter l'intimité la douleur
de la famille et des proches de vincent
lambert
la seule leçon que nous pouvons retenir
de cette situation est que chacun
remplisse ses directives anticipées
chaque personne majeure peut depuis la
loi que l'ess leonetti de 2016
rédigé par avance une déclaration pour
préciser ses volontés en fin de vie
chacun peut inscrire son refus ou sa
volonté de poursuivre de limiter ou
d'arrêter les traitements ou les actes
médicaux les consignes données dans les
directives anticipées permettent aux
équipes médicales de prendre en charge
les patients en respectant leur propre
volonté
ces directives anticipées on peut les
remplir sur internet
elles sont également accessibles dans le
dossier médical partagé
j'engage chaque français aujourd'hui à
les français à les renseigner
je vous remercie merci valable
l'histoire